hey 42 here do you worry about a zombie
uprising well fear not the US Department
of Defense has you covered the Pentagon
has created a comprehensive plan
detailing how to counter a zombie
apocalypse created in 2011 it's called
con plan ate ate ate ate and outlines
the precise steps to US government and
military would take to combat a zombie
uprising I know what you're thinking
this must be a joke the government can't
possibly have spent hundreds of
man-hours on preparing this document
well fortunately for obsessive tinned
food hoarders it's no joke but don't
worry as far as we know the government
isn't expecting a zombie attack the plan
was actually created as part of a
training exercise for security personnel
at the Pentagon but when they finished
writing a document they fought it was so
damn good that they ought to keep it you
know just in case it now resides hidden
away deep inside the Pentagon's secret
network of files right alongside plans
such as what to do in case of a nuclear
war or a civil uprising for example but
luckily for us the document has been
unclassified and yes it actually has a
pretty picture of a zombie on the front
cover they just couldn't help themselves
could they so what does this zombie
master defense plan contain the document
first describes the eight different
types of zombies because you need to
know exactly what you're dealing with
before you can defeat it the first type
is pathogenic zombies this is your
bog-standard zombie created when a
life-form is infected by a rogue virus
or bacteria you know like in practically
every zombie film ever second
irradiation zombies created when an
organism is subjected to an extreme
dosage of radiation thirdly evil magic
zombies yes the Pentagon actually came
up of that name I'll let the document
itself explain this one since they
worded it so eloquently EMGs our zombie
life-forms created via some form of a
cult experimentation in what might
otherwise be referred to as evil magic
and to think this was actually written
by the people running the defense
sector of the world's largest superpower
next our space zombies not much
explanation needed here they're zombies
that come from outer space after that we
have weaponized zombies these are
zombies that are intentionally created
by an enemy group or state by a
biomechanical engineering to be used as
a weapon against America at number 6 is
symbionts induced zombies this is when
another life-form latches onto an
organism and controls its brain and
therefore their body in a zombie-like
manner this actually does happen to ants
when they become infected with a fungus
known as cordyceps they turn into zombie
ants could it happen to humans too
possibly next are vegetarian zombies
they pose no direct threat to humans
apart from being a complete boring
parties but their obsession with eating
crops could cause massive deforestation
and eliminate food sources worldwide
causing mass starvation the Kahn plan
até até até até documents actually notes
that instead of moaning brains
vegetarian zombies would most likely say
grains and lastly we have the scariest
zombie type of all chicken zombies now
chicken zombies may sound utterly
ridiculous but these are the only type
of zombie that actually exists today
when an old hen is to be euthanized
because it can no longer lay eggs and
gas is used to end its life and it is
buried underground however if the
euthanization was performed incorrectly
for instance of an incorrect dosage of
gases used then after a few days
underground the chicken can actually
come back to life and dig its way out of
the ground at a zombie-like manner then
stumble around aimlessly for a while
before its internal organs eventually
fail there have been numerous documented
cases of this happening in farms all
over the world
zombie chickens don't pose any threat to
human life but the Pentagon obviously
thinks they're terrifying enough to
warrant a place in their zombie defense
plan so that's the preliminaries covered
but what steps does the US government
plan to
take if any of these eight types of
zombies were to start a zombie uprising
well the country would first go into a
state of martial law an attempt to
maintain order and allow appropriate
force to be used against the zombie
horde the CDC would also be called in to
help control the spread of infection
between hosts interestingly the plan
notes that zombies are neither
classified as human nor animal life and
therefore the military is free to
completely bypass human animal rights
laws when counter-attacking the zombies
so they can do whatever the hell they
like to them the document makes
essential observations about zombie
behavior I don't know where they got
their research from but presumably the
Pentagon just binge watch zombie flicks
the document notes that zombies can't be
reasoned with and don't fear pain or
death therefore riot control strategies
will be completely useless and the only
way to effectively deal with them is a
shot to the head once killed a zombie
cadaver should be burnt to prevent the
spread of pathogens add possible
reanimation of the corpse oh and zombies
can't swim the document makes this very
clear throughout their four rivers and
other waterways will be the recommended
escape route for most citizens all the
various measures that the plan suggests
for dealing with the zombie horde are
neatly segmented into five key steps in
the document shape deter seized
initiative dominate and stabilize the
last step involves finding and
eliminating the very last zombie
strongholds and restoring basic services
to communities sadly had no point does
the Pentagon's plan suggest going down
the Winchester for a pint shameful
really thanks for watching having a
quite simply the undisputed Nobel Prize
winners of underwater communication
because they use farts to talk to each
other normally government combat obesity
with hopeless advertising campaigns and
even taxing junk food but Japan went the
extra mile and simply made it illegal to
be fat